- If you're going to work tomorrow
because that's what you did yesterday
you're not going to be as good
tomorrow as you were yesterday.
I never had anybody
say something like that
to me, "You could be a great one.
"You could be the national champion."
Some people are about as committed as
a kamikaze pilot on his 39th mission.
When I was boy, during the Depression,
we lived next door to some rich folks.
I knew they were rich for two reasons.
Number one they had a cook.
Number two, the cook
had something to cook.
Where would my integrity
be if I came to you
unprepared to make
something, a presentation
that could make a difference in your life?
And, when I choose to eat too much today
I have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow.
You see, most people
never dare to evaluate
really where they are.
"Zig," they tell me, "you could
sell anything to anybody."
And I said, "Yeah, they lied to ya."
So many times the employee
goes to the employer
and say, "Give me a raise then I'll start
"coming to work on time."
- He was an American author, salesman,
and motivational speaker.
He served in United States
Navy during World War II
from 1943 to 1945.
In 1968 he became Vice
President and Training Director
of the Automotive Performance Company.
He's Zig Zigler and here's my take on his
Top 10 Rules for Success.
(air rushes)
(thuds)
- When you're asleep,
ladies and gentlemen,
you need your dreams.
I'm here to tell you that
when you're wide awake
you also need your dreams.
You must have your goals.
You'll never make it is
a wandering generality.
You must become a meaningful specific.
If you're going to work tomorrow
because that's what you did yesterday
you're not going to be
as good tomorrow as you
were yesterday because
now you're two days older
and no closer to the goal
which you do not have.
You can't make it as
a wandering generality
- Tell us about some of
the jobs that you've held
over the years selling
and what you've sold
and some of the lessons
that you've learned
in selling over the years.
- Well, I sold heavy
duty waterless cookware
on the door-to-door demonstration plan.
And, that was a marvelous experience.
It took me the first two and a half years
I struggled financially.
Now, that doesn't mean I didn't sell a lot
because I did.
I sold my furniture, sold my car.
(laughs)
And, that's fairly close to
the truth, it really was.
Then I went to a meeting
and a man named P.C. Merrill
who's an American Indian persuaded me that
I could be the number
one salesman in America
out of the 7,000 member sales force.
He said, "You've got
everything that it takes
"to be a great salesman
if you just believed in
"yourself and went to work
on a regular schedule."
- And, this is in a cookware business?
- That's right, and I
put on the demonstration
on door to door sales and so forth.
I'd never had anybody say
something like that to me.
"You could be a great one, you could be
"the national champion."
Now, I've always been loved, but nobody
ever thought of me as a champion.
Because of Mister Merrill's integrity
and because he had written
the training program
and because he had set all of the records
I took him absolutely at his word.
The previous year I had
not been in the top 5,000
out that 7,000 member sales force.
But, the year after
Mister Merrill got through
with me I was number two out of the 7,000,
had received the best promotion that
was available in the company at that time.
And, the interesting
thing about the success
that year he did not really
teach me that much about sales.
I'd been in it two and
half years at that point,
but what he did teach
me was about who I was.
The picture I had of myself
changed dramatically.
I started thinking as a
champion and performing
as a champion.
And, I did finish number two and had
that wonderful promotion.
Commitment plays heavily in everything.
If you've made a commitment when you hit
the rough spots, not if,
when you hit the rough spots
your immediate thought is,
"How can I solve the problem?"
If you have not made the
commitment when you hit
the rough spot whether it's
in marriage or education
or career or whatever
your first thought is,
"Man, how can I get out of this deal?"
And so, that commitment plays a huge role.
And, some people are about as committed
as a kamikaze pilot on it's 39th mission.
I mean, they don't really
take it that seriously.
I was raised in the little town
of Yazoo City, Mississippi.
Now, I know a lot of folks
go 'round the country
trying to impress people by
claiming to be from Yazoo City.
(laughs)
But, I really am and
when I was a boy during
the Depression we lived next
door to some rich folks.
I knew they were rich for two reasons.
Number on they had a cook.
Number two the cook had something to cook.
(laughs)
During the Depression that
was a sure sign of wealth.
I was over there for lunch
one day, as I tried to be
everyday,
(laughs)
and don't misunderstand that.
Even though there was a
Depression on we certainly
had plenty to eat at my house.
I know we had plenty
because if I ever passed
my plate for seconds
they'd always tell me,
"No, you've had plenty."
So, I know we had plenty.
Now, the cook brought the biscuits out,
and this is not an exaggeration,
those biscuits were not
as thick as my wrist was.
And, I looked at 'em for
a moment, I said Maude,
what in the world
happened to your biscuits?
She reared back gave a big old tummy laugh
and said, "Well, I'll tell
you about those biscuits."
She said, "They squatted
to rise," but she said
they just got cooked in the squat.
(laughs)
You anybody that's getting
cooked in the squat?
You know anybody who's
going to do something
just as soon as or they're
half a mind to do such
and such a thing?
You ever have anybody say,
"Well, wait till the kids
"get out of school and then
I'll really get involved
"in this project.
"We got so many things going on right now,
"wait till they're out of school.
"Wait till the summer time comes then I'll
"really get busy."
The kids get out of school
you know what they say then?
"Well, I didn't realize
it but I got to take
"the kids somewhere every day.
"I had more time when they were in school.
"Wait till they get
back in school and then
"I'll really get busy."
Kids get back in school,
you know what they say then?
"Well, for the first time in
19 years Dearhold Centralized
"finally got a winning
football team and you
"got to support the kids there.
"Wait till after the football season's
"then I'll really get busy."
Football season ends, you
know what they say then?
"Well, here it is
Thanksgiving and Christmas
"and New Years and people
don't want to be bothered
"with this sort of thing
this time of the year.
"Wait until the after the
first of the year, man,
"then I'll really get busy."
After the first of the year
you know what they say?
"Well, it's the weather.
"Did you ever see weather
like this in Chicago,
"or San Francisco or Dallas or wherever.
"Wait till the weather
settles down and then
"I'll really get busy.
"Oh, I know what you're thinking.
"You're thinking I've lost interest in it,
"but that's not the way I do things.
"Just let me tell you
the way I do things now.
"Here's the way I am, see,
this is just the way I do it.
(crowd applauds)
"See, the way I do things is
I get everything organized.
"I get it lined up, I
have everything in just
"such and such order and
then man, once I get it
"all put together that's
when I really get after it.
"I mean, that's just,
I've always been that way,
"do things that way.
"I know some of these
other folks are ahead
"of me right now but you
just wait, I'll catch 'em.
"But this weather it is just so horrible.
"Wait till it clears up."
And, the weather clears up and
you know what they say then?
"Well, here it is it's
Easter time and Easter time
"you know that's a family time
"and we always spend a
lot of time together.
"And, you said so yourself,
the family's extremely
"important to you, you do
the work for the family
"and if you can't spend
some time with them
"you might as well not do all the work.
"I mean, wait till
after Easter's over then
"I'll really get busy."
And then, after Easter
you know what they say?
"At long last, we've got
some beautiful weather
"and I haven't hit a
golf ball or wet a hook
"in I don't know when.
"Man, I got to have some
r and r, I've got to have
"some rest and relaxation.
"And, you said you
can't work all the time.
"I mean, an individual needs
some time with themself.
"Wait till I relax a little bit and man,
"then I'll really get after it."
And finally, they get
after it a little bit
or when they have their fun and relaxation
then they say, "Well, it's
almost time for the kids
"to get out of school."
And, that's where we came in.
As we say down home
folks, you can put this
in your pipe and smoke
it 'cause it's the truth.
The people who wait for
Aunt Matilda to move out
or John to get onto the
day shift or the new models
to come out or the new
mayor to come in or for
the new advertising
campaign to get started
the people who wait on the
new senator in Washington
or until inflation slows or
the rate of interest come down,
the people who wait for
changes to take place out there
before they do the changing in here
are flat going to end up
getting cooked in the squat.
The rule is simple, you
do it now, you do it now.
How many of you feel like
I've made this talk before?
Can I see your hand please?
Several hundred times,
I made it yesterday.
You know what I did between
yesterday and today?
I spent over six hours
getting ready for today.
You see, I think it would
be arrogant if I thought
I could stand up and
spit it out just because
I did it yesterday or hundreds of times.
That's arrogance, that's
when Buster Douglas
knocks out Mike Tyson.
That's when an expansion team in Houston
beats an established NFL team in Dallas.
I dare not, look at the
people here, several thousand.
I'm taking over an hour.
That's several thousands hours of time.
Where would my integrity be if I came here
unprepared to make
something, a presentation
that could make a difference in your life.
There is no way, you got to prepare for it
ladies and gentlemen.
Almost did not go to the
most important sales meeting
I would ever have missed.
That morning I awakened, I'd been up there
in Charlotte all day long in a meeting
and didn't learn anything.
Five o'clock the alarm
clock goes off and it was
an alarm clock in those days,
now it's an opportunity clock.
If I can hear that it means
I've got an opportunity
to get up and go.
If I can't hear it that might mean I
done got up and gone.
Well, anyhow,
(laughs)
went off, we were living
in little three room
apartment above a grocery
store, five o'clock
the weather was horrible.
When the clock went off
I looked out and I said
no sane person would ever get in a little
Crosley automobile without
a heater in weather
like this and drive all
the way to Charlotte
to go to another meeting.
So, I lay back down.
As I lay down the words
of my mother came back
to me, "Son, if you work
for a man you work for him
"all the way, you're
loyal to him in every way.
"And, if your word is no
good, you're no good."
I had promised this
company, which had taken me
two months to get the job
that if they would give me
the opportunity I'd be
at every sales meeting,
I'd be at every training session.
And, in two and a half
years, despite my lack
of success, I had been
at every sales meeting,
at every training session
and I'd never even been late.
The words of my mother came back.
I rolled out of bed, went to the meeting,
that's the one that changed my life.
- How did it change your life?
- It changed my life
because that's the day
that Mister Merrill persuaded me that
I could be the champion.
- Comes full circle now.
- Ah man, it sure did
and so it made all the
difference in the world.
I want to talk a little bit
about goals on the light of
how do you lose 37
pounds and write a book.
I'm just going to kind of to
give you that as an example.
For 24 years of my adult life, by choice,
I weighed well over 200 pounds.
I say by choice because,
you see, I have never
accidentally eaten anything.
(laughs)
I mean, it's always been deliberate.
And, when I choose to eat too much today
I have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow.
You can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not set them.
Now, if you choose not to set
them you got to understand
that the consequences
are not going to be good
down the road.
For 24 years I was going
to lose that weight.
As a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several
thousand pounds of weight.
How many of you already
know what I'm talking about.
But, it wasn't until I
wrote it down, put a date
on it, listed the obstacles
I had to overcome,
identified the people, the
groups, the organizations
I needed to work with,
spelled out a plan of action,
set that time limit in
there, and identified
all of the benefits to me,
it as only when I did that
that the goal became a
reality and I lost the weight.
For 10 or 15 years I was
going to write a book.
You know anybody who's a
going to do just a whole
lot of things, folks?
I was going to write a book.
But, it wasn't until I got busy
writing the book and writing
the plans first before the
book ever materialized.
Now, if I sound like
I'm trying to sell you
on having goals, how many of
you are getting close already?
How many of you are becoming convinced
right quick like that you
need to have those goals?
There's no question about it.
The immortal J.C. Penny,
many, many years ago
said, "Give me a stock clerk with a goal
"and I'll give you a
man who'll make history.
"But give me a man without a goal and I'll
"give you a stock clerk."
Now, the interesting thing is goals
do not care who has them.
Let me give you a classic
example of the way they work.
In 1950, a war torn devastated Japan,
a nation who had lost an
incredibly high percentage of
it's young man, their
cities were in ruins,
they'd been bombed out, but
in 1950 they got together.
They meaning industry and
government got together
and set a goal.
The goal was "we're going to
be the number one nation in
"the world during the 1950s in
the production of textiles."
In 1959, ladies and gentleman,
they accomplished that objective.
In 1960, they set another goal.
"We're going to be the number
one nation in the world
"in the production of steel."
And, when you understand
there's no iron ore
in Japan of any
significance, there's no coal
of any significance
there, "We're going to be
"the nation in the world in
the production of steel,"
it seemed like an absurd goal.
And yet, they reached their objectives.
They had taken all of the steps.
In 1970, the Japanese set another goal.
They said, "During the 70s
we'll be the number one
"nation in the world in the
production of automobiles."
They missed it folks, one year.
It took them until 1980.
In 1980 they set another goal.
And, this time their goal
was, "We're going to be
"the number one nation in the world
"in the production of
computers and electronics."
Yes indeed, ladies and gentlemen,
you absolutely must have those goals.
Let me share with you a true story out of
my notebook of life.
A number of years ago
got an incredible letter
from a gentleman in Toronto
with a substantial check in it.
He said, "My friend
Steve Walker is following
"the wrong role model.
"He's working himself to death,
his family's falling apart.
"His health is in danger.
"And, he's modeled himself out of his boss
"and he trusts you and respects you.
"If you will give us
one hour I will fly him
"to Dallas and give you this check."
Wouldn't you love to
have a friend like that?
I sent the check back and
I said, "Come on down."
Steve and I had quite a little talk.
And, in our talk I asked him
why he had such a role model?
What about this man that
made him so completely
important in his life?
And he said, "Well, he's
the most successful man
"I have ever known."
And I said, "Well Steve,
what do you call success?"
Now, it took several minutes for him to go
down the list.
But, the interesting
thing is though their not
in the same order that I have put them,
or we'll list them now.
These are the eight things that he said
he really considered to be successful.
If a man was happy and
healthy and at least
reasonably prosperous and
secure, if he had friends,
and peace of mind, and
good family relationships,
and the hope that future's
going to be better
he said, "I consider
that man as successful."
Now, I'm going to really
encourage you to take some
notes right here.
And all I want you to do,
and you'll be the only one
that'll see it somewhere
right as I go down the list
write whether you get a plus on that one
or a minus on that one.
You'll be the only one to see it,
but it might be an eye opener.
You see, most people never
dare to evaluate really
where they are.
And, you got to know
where you are before you
can really determine
your chances of getting
what you really want out of life.
And so, I said to Steve,
I said, "I understand
"that your boss is very important to you.
"You consider to him to be successful."
When he finally got through
with the identification
as I said earlier these
were the eight things
that he said, "I think
that's important for success,
"to measure success."
I said, "Well Steve, let
me ask you now as far as
"happy's concerned tell
how happy is your boss?"
He said, "Oh, I don't
think he's happy at all."
I said, "Why not?"
He said, "Well, I've never heard him laugh
"and he seldom smiles and
besides that he's got ulcers."
I said, "Well, do give
him a plus or a minus?"
He said, "Oh, you give him a minus."
Please grade yourself as we go.
This is so important for you.
Then I said, "That also
tells me something about
"his health if he's got those ulcers.
"Do I give him a plus or a minus?"
He said, "You give him a minus."
I said, "That also says something, Steve,
"about his peace of mind because you don't
"get ulcers because of what you eat
"but what's eating you."
I said, "Do we give
him a plus or a minus?"
He said, "We give him a minus."
I said, "Steve, I've asked
you one question about
"what success is, what
balance is, what's important
"to you, one question
and your boss comes up
"with three minuses."
I said, "Tell me how prosperous he is."
He said, "Man, he's got
money running out of
"his ears and he's getting more everyday."
I said, "We give him a plus
on that one, don't we?"
He said, "We sure do."
I said, "How secure is your boss?"
He said, "Well, he's secure
as money can make you."
And I said, "Well Steve,
let me ask you did you read
"where two billionaire brothers here
"in Dallas went bankrupt?"
I said, "How does your boss compare?"
"Oh man, he doesn't have
that kind of money."
"Did you read where our
ex-governor was worth
"a hundred million dollars at
one point, he's now bankrupt.
"How does your boss compare?"
"Oh, he doesn't have that kind of money."
Now understand Steve equated security with
corporate position and bucks in the bank.
So, I said, "Well Steve,
let me ask you would we
"give your boss a plus or
a minus or just a question
"mark on that?"
He said, "Let's be generous
and give him a question mark."
I said, "How many friends
does your boss have?"
I hope you're marking these for you.
"How many friends, real
friends does your boss have?"
He said, "I don't think he's got any.
"I'm not his friend I just
happen to admire the guy.
"To tell you the truth
he's somewhat of a jerk."
And, I said, "Okay, we give
him a minus on that one."
I said, "Tell me about his family."
He said, "Well, his wife's divorcing him."
"Well, that one's easy to answer."
I said, "How much hope does
he have for the future?"
He said, "Well, afore I
started talking to you
"I thought he had a lot.
(laughs)
"But, right now I don't
think he's got any."
Why did that statement come forth?
Because for the first
time he had evaluated it.
That's what we need to
do, evaluate where we are.
Are we investing our time properly,
using our resources properly?
What will the end results be?
Well, then I said to
Steven when that was over,
"We give him the minus there."
I said, "Steve, of the eight
things that you consider
"marks of success he gets one, two, three,
"four, five, six minuses.
"He gets one plus and one question mark."
I asked Steven a question,
I'm going to ask you
the same question.
"Steve, would you swap places
with your boss right now
"knowing what you know?"
He looked at me kind of stunned.
He slowly rose to his feet and said,
"No, I wouldn't."
Would you?
I never will forget this particular thing.
On the radio interviews
I was having done and did
at least 90% of the first 25 of them
would always start with the same thing.
"Zig, they tell me you could
sell anything to anybody."
And I said, "yeah, they lied
to ya when they said that
"because you've just
described a con artist."
No legitimate professional sales person
would ever dream of
selling anything that he
did not fervently believe
was in the best interest
of the person he was selling to.
Of all of the qualities a
good sales person must have
number one is integrity
because if they don't
have that, see we are
trained as sales people
to persuade other people
to buy, to make decisions.
And, an unethical sales
person can persuade people
to buy things that they
don't need, are overpriced,
or they pressure them into buying it.
A legitimate integrity driven sales person
will only sell a product
that will enable him
to sell them again and again and again,
a product he would sell to
his mother, in other words.
That's the kind of sales person who has
long term balanced success.
Now, unfortunately a lot
of people are standing
I front of a stove a life and they say,
"Now stove, you give me some heat then
"I'll put some wood in you."
That ain't the way it works.
You got to put something in
before you can get anything out.
So, many times you know
the employee goes to
the employer and say,
"Give me a raise and then
"I start coming to work on time."
Or, so many times they
will come to 'em and say
"Make me the boss.
"Now, I know I haven't
been here very long,
"don't really deserve to be the boss
"but I just function better when I am
"in charge of things.
"You reward me now, then I promise you
"I'll learn what this business
is all about later on.
"Reward me now and I'll produce later."
Doesn't work that way.
Can't you just see a
youngster in a school saying,
"Teacher, if I take a
failing grade home my
"parents are going to skin me alive.
"Pass me on this quarter
and next time I'll study
"more than anybody else.
"Reward me now, I'll produce later."
It doesn't work that way.
Can't you just see an
old farmer standing out
in the fields in October
and saying, "Lord, I know
"I didn't plant a thing
this year, but if you'll
"give me a big crop this
year I'll plant more
"than anybody next year."
It ain't that way folks,
you got to put something in
before you can expect to get anything out.
Well, he's just a pumping away,
"that's hard, it's all good."
I mean, the question is
how much pumping are you
going to to do before I drink the water.
And finally, old Bernard
said, "you know Jimmy,
"I don't believe there's
any water down there."
Jimmy said, "Yeah there is, Bernard."
You know, in south
Alabama the wells are deep
and oh we're glad they're
deep because the deeper
the well the cooler, the
cleaner, the sweeter,
the purer, the better tasting the water.
And, isn't that true of life?
Isn't it true that if
you can become an M.D.
by six weeks of summer
school that the rewards
would be almost minimal
or nothing and how many
patients would you have?
Isn't it true if you become a sales expert
in three days of a training
school that the rate
of pay would go down rather radically?
Isn't it true that anything worth doing
is worth doing poorly
until you can learn to do it well?
We'll never know how many kids have missed
a college scholarship
because they didn't study
an average of 10 more minutes a day.
We will never know how we
come so close to a promotion
but we're get discouraged
and quit too soon.
We'll never know how much
more success we would
have had had we just had a
little more pumping in there
and pumping, pumping, pumping, pumping.
Well, finally Old Bernard
just got disgusted
threw up his hands he
said, "Jimmy, there's just
"no water down there."
Jimmy said, "Don't stop
Bernard, don't stop
"if you stop the water's
going to go all the way
"back down and then
you're going to have to
"start all over."
The reality is folks, and I'm
totally convinced of this,
this is the story of
America, this is your story.
This is the story of success.
This is the story of life.
I believe with all of my
heart that if you will
pump long enough and hard enough and
enthusiastically enough
that eventually the reward
is going to follow the effort.
And then, once that water
starts to flow all you
got to do is just keep a
little easy, steady pressure
on it and you're going to get more water
than you can possibly use.
The basic problem is
this so many times people
get involved in something and then say,
"Well, I'll give it a
try and if it works out
"that'll be good and if doesn't work out
"I mean, hey I'm not going to kill myself.
"You know what I mean, feller?"
Well, I got to tell you something folks
you're going to pump forever like that
before anything happens.
When you get into
something grab that sucker
and get with it.
And then, once the water starts to flow
then, ladies and gentlemen, that's what
strategy for success is all about.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Alvinladen asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want
me to profile next leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Zig's top ten rules
meant the most to you, what
impact it had on your life,
what change your going
to make now as a result
of watching this video.
I'm really curious to find out.
Leave it in the comments below
and I'll join the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(air rushes)
(thuds)
- You need to read at
least 20 minutes every day.
Now, I spend about two
hours a day or more,
but you got to understand
this is my business,
this is my life, this is my profession.
I got to do it.
Fortunately, I just
absolutely love to do it.
But, 20 minutes a day will
make a dramatic difference.
Now obviously, I'm talking
about reading something good,
powerful, positive,
biographies, autobiographies,
self-help books, motivational
books, books about
your business, your
profession, the industry
of which you are a part,
books about human nature,
how to deal with people.
If you are an average reader,
that's 220 words a minute
if you will just read 20 minutes a day
at the end of the year
you will have read 20
200 page books.
That is 18 more than the average
American reads in a year's time.
That will give you a colossal advantage
in whatever it is that you're going.
I listened to the people
who were successful
in selling their product.
I would learn new things
from different ones,
new approaches and
that's where you must be
a constant student.
A lot of people are
afraid to try anything new
because they are afraid that
they will be embarrassed
until they get good at it.
Well, one of my favorite sayings is
the most important thing you can do is
to understand that anything worth doing
is worth doing poorly.
(laughs)
- What do you mean by that?
- Until you can learn to do it well.
My first few sales calls were pathetic,
but I knew it was worth
doing so I kept after it.
My first few speeches
were a disaster but I
believed that I could develop into that.
So, I kept at it until I
could do it effectively.
And, all skills are exactly the same way.
No running back that sets the record ever
set a record the first time
he picked up a football.
And, you can go the right
down the line with that.
So, if it's worth doing
and you believe in it
go ahead and fail.
And, the more times you fail the closer
you get into success because you should be
learning on every simple
thing that you do.
A number of years ago Laurie Majors,
my executive assistant, got a phone call
from a lady in Birmingham, Alabama.
At the end of the conversation she said,
"Zig," she said, "I
believe this woman thinks
"she's got an impossible
problem, but I believe
"you can solve that
problem with her in just
"a few minutes if you will
spend that time with her."
I said, "Well Laurie, tell
her to meet me back stage,
"I'll get there about 10 minutes early."
My schedule was such that
that was about all I had.
Well, I got there and
I was backstage behind
the curtain on one side she
spotted me from the other side
and as she walked across
the stage I have never seen
as much anger in a human being in my life
as I saw in her.
She almost started crying when she saw me.
She said, "oh, I'm just
so glad to see you.
"I got this horrible job, I hate it.
"I hate everything about it.
"I hate everybody down there."
I mean, you're talking about
negative Nell, she was it.
She said, "Can you help me?"
Now, understand I've only
got about 10 minutes.
So, I looked at her and
one thing I have learned
I don't do counseling,
but I talk with a lot
of people who do in
psychologists, psychiatry,
and the ministry.
And, they tell me that
everybody who comes to you
with a problem are not necessarily looking
for a solution.
I couldn't understand
that for a long time.
Why do they bring you a problem if they
don't want to solve it?
Well, I can tell you why.
They want to tell you
about it, you about it,
you about it, you about
it, and you about it
and if you foul up the
deal and solve the problem
they can't tell you again, you again.
They want the attention
that goes with the problem.
And every company just about it has
that kind of an individual.
They want the attention that goes with
griping and complaining.
Well, I looked at the lady
and I wasn't unkindly,
but firmly I said to her,
"Yes, and you know ma'am
"I'm afraid your problem
is about to get worse."
She said, "What do you mean?"
I said, "I believe they're
going to fire you."
(laughs)
She was stunned.
I couldn't have stunned her more if I
had hit her in the face
with a bucket of ice water.
She said, "Fire me, why on
Earth would they fire me?"
The inflection in her
voice clearly said "they're
"the bad guys, I'm the good guy.
"Why don't they fire them and keep me?"
Have you ever noticed that
people who are the problem
never recognize that they are?
They're in complete denial.
They think denial is
just a river in Egypt.
(laughs)
"Why would they fire me?"
I said, "Ma'am, I don't
believe there's a company
"in America big enough
to contain this much
"poison in one small spot."
(laughs)
Have you ever noticed
that when somebody's about
to lose something they've
been complaining about
whether it's a car, a home,
a mate, a job, or whatever,
when all of a sudden it appears
they're going to lose 'em
it takes on brand new value.
She looked at me and said,
"Well, what can I do?"
I said, "Do you really want to know?"
She said, "Yes, I do that's
the reason I came to see you.
"I came looking for help
but you sure haven't
"been any help so far."
(laughs)
I said, "Well ma'am, I've
got an idea and I will
"absolutely guarantee you
it positively, definitely
"absolutely will work
if you will just do it."
She said, "I'll try
anything, within reason."
I said, "Okay, when you get home tonight
"all of your household tasks are complete,
"it's bedtime get off in
a room right by yourself,
"get a sheet of paper
out and at the top of it
"write I like my job because"
She interrupted me, she
said, "That'll be easy.
"I don't like nothing about that job.
"Don't like nothing about
those people down there."
(laughs)
And, I said, "Just as
a matter of curiosity
"do you work there for benevolent
reasons or do they pay you
"for working there?"
She said, "Well, I got
to confess, they pay me."
And said, "You don't like to be paid."
Oh, she said, "Yes, I do."
I said, "Okay, tell you
what you do open your
"notebook right now
we'll start our list of
"the things you like about
your job, they pay you
"for working there and you
do like it, don't you?"
She said, "Absolutely."
But, she just stood there.
I said, "No, open your
notebook now and we'll get
"busy on the list."
She just stood there.
I said, "Ma'am, let me
tell you what my experience
"in life has been.
"I've discovered that
in 100% of the cases,
"no exception, people who
won't take step number one
"never take step number two."
You see, she had come to me
with an impossible dream.
Her dream was that nice
Mister Zigler was going to
solve all of her problems
and she would live
happily ever after.
But folks, I got news for you
I can't solve her problems.
I can't solve your problems.
But, I will give you some steps that I'll
absolutely, definitely, and
positively will work for you
as it worked eventually for her.
I said, "Well ma'am, let
me tell you something.
"Unless you're willing
to take step number one
"right now it's been
nice talking with you."
She angrily opened her notebook.
Before we got through there were 22 things
she liked about her job.
Not only did they pay
her for working there
they paid her above average.
She had three weeks vacation with pay.
She had a retirement program.
She was in on profit sharing.
She had health insurance, life insurance,
and an accident insurance.
She lived less than 10 minutes from home.
She was in on management decisions.
The company set her to
three seminars a year
to be paid for.
She had her own private
office and parking place.
22 things that she liked about her job.
Now, I said, "Ma'am,
when you get home tonight
"everything is finished, get off in a room
"right by yourself, close
the doors, change one
"word from I like my job to I love my job.
"Get in front of that mirror,"
and folks I cannot say
this strongly enough,
but I'm going to try.
The eyes are the windows of the soul.
Look yourself in the
eye and with excitement
and enthusiasm say, "I
love my job because they
"pay me for working there.
"I love my job because they pay me
"above average for working there.
"I love my job because they have
"a wonderful insurance program.
"I love my job before every
one of the statements."
You will sleep better that night.
You see, there's something hidden in what
I'm saying to you now.
When she says I like my
job she's really saying,
"I'm grateful for my job."
And, of all of the emotions
we can have according to
Ann Selia the number one
stress specialist in America,
the healthiest of all human
emotions is gratitude.
I said, "You go down
that list, I like my job,
"I love my job, rather.
"That is a way of gratitude.
"You'll sleep better the first night.
"Tomorrow morning when you get up get back
"in front of the mirror
just before you go to work
"get back in front of the
mirror and repeat the process
"again with excitement and enthusiasm.
"I love my job because, and
take the list with you."
Because, the reality is,
you see, you will have
started a change from a fault
finder to a good finder.
Some people really do
find fault like there's
a reward for it, they really do.
Take the list with you
and you will be able
to add to that list absolutely guaranteed.
Do this every morning and every night
and you will have an astonishing recovery
from this advanced case
of stinkin' thinkin'.
Now, I didn't say that to
her, but I'm saying it to you.
That's what it was.
It was an advanced case
of stinkin' thinkin'.
Well, six weeks later I was
back in Birmingham, Alabama.
I was doing a follow up sales seminar.
Now, the lady was not in
sales, but she had been
listening to my tapes,
she had been listening
to Automobile University.
And, she had discovered
that everybody sells.
Everybody who will ever
hear this is in selling
whether you're a school
teacher, a civil service
worker, a military personnel,
an executive secretary
it doesn't make any
difference what you do.
You sell every day of your life.
There she was at the
sales seminar seated on
the front row, grinning
so wide she could have
eaten a banana sideways.
I'm tell ya' you're talking about somebody
that was excited and she was turned on.
I said, "Well, how you doing?"
She grinned even more broadly and said,
"Mister Zigler I'm doing wonderfully well
"and thank you for asking."
She said, "You cannot
believe how much those people
"down there have changed."
(laughs)
I got to lay it the line folks,
you're not going to change
anybody else till you change you.
Everything really does begin with you.
Now, you see, the
unfortunate thing this lady
had been raised in a very
negative environment.
First, her parents had
told her she'd never
amount to anything.
They said, "You're always
late, you're always sloppy.
"Why can't you be like your brother
"or you sister or whatever."
When she got mad her
husband had contended it
and so her self-talk had
become completely negative.
Everything that she said
about herself was negative.
"Like dad said, I'll
never amount to anything.
"Or, like my husband says
I can't do anything right."
But, when she started changing the input
then some radical changes took place.
(digital tones)
- [Announcer] Zigler, Zigler
inspiring true performance.